thank you guys and we do have hans
neiman hans seemed like a tough position
you came up with this interesting idea
we hadn't seen before with c5 tell us a
little bit about that
yeah well uh first of all this bishop b3
move
is slightly uh it's not the main line
the main line is actually not f1 yeah
and i had some ideas there which i
thought would be a nice surprise and uh
so that was my main point um
but bishop b3 is sort of the
uh stopping knight g6 because then
there's d4
so so the point behind knight to e7 is
that you can't play d4 because of knight
c6
and this is a common idea this is also
an idea there was a game actually let's
say the pawn is on a2 the pawn was on a7
the bishop is on b6 yes this idea is a
position there was a game um i think
alexenko caruana from the candidates
2021 so this idea of going back and
forth is a nice little trick
especially because he played knight dd2
first yes this is like you could argue
it's a slightly inaccurate order um
because you sort of
aren't able to punish 97 directly like
let's say you played until 92 rook e1
castles
h3
let's say 97 now then uh d d d4 and you
can sort of punish this directly um so
the main idea was just to sort of uh
avoid this immediate d4 break um which
is by getting sort of a semi-closed
position that i had more knowledge about
so okay we can go back to c5 yes
so yeah i didn't check it too much it
was sort of a spur of the moment i was
not too sure about what opening to play
uh
i could have been better prepared in
this specific game of course um
but obviously not if one i don't
remember you know of course what i
remember is that actually a5 the most
precise move here in this position
yeah that's what i remembered and then
uh you play bishop to e6 and then i and
then this sort of weird move knight to
c4
um when i saw this i was like this is a
bit weird i don't think the engine will
give this
i don't remember i think maybe rick's
eight is a move um but this looked
pretty fine to me it's like a weird
marshall yeah and um i guess you could
sort of have uh
the bridgepoint a7 isn't that bad in the
marshall because you sort of always
stopping the d4 break which is the main
positional break in these positions it's
usually d4 and it's never really working
here so i thought that it was possible
for him to sort of lack a direct plan
which he kind of did he went he brought
the knight two to e3 which
i don't think
from what i remember knight to g3 and
then sort of ideas with knight h2 and
knight g4 and knight h1n5 was the most
precise so
i didn't think this was so critical but
um i think my main mistake was actually
after the move uh was a bishop v8 um yes
so
if instead of bishop a7 so after he
plays with a5 i should of course
understand uh that the idea is to play
bishop a4 and c4 this is sort of the
only way that he can time the closing of
the position
to where i don't get direct counter play
so in anticipation of this bishop a4 c4
idea i should of course play knight to
g6
um and and bishop b8 is even stupider um
in this specific position because as we
saw in the game the b4 brick the bishop
is on b8 yeah and it's basically wasting
two tempo so let's say i play knight g6
here yeah and i'm again preparing d5
bishop for queen c8 c4
uh white could be even uh lost after
knight to f4 attacking d3
uh okay so the queen is not on c8 here
seriously i just missed it yeah so queen
to ca yes c4 and out of four and uh here
with bishop h3 is coming um
and uh maybe even if pictures isn't
coming
i don't really see how i'm worse here
even i could play g5 to consolidate this
i think i had a game against fabi and
like uh some
some online tournaments at rapture's
championship and he had he has a very
similar structure i just remind you of
that but
of course i should play knight g6 right
preparing uh this this entire sequence
so um this was just bishop bait was was
quite stupid um because i just
underestimated this and underestimated
his move knight to d5 which was
extremely strong
i think it's the only move
to sort of maintain control because
and then here he has sort of a long
transitional edge but why is the bishop
on b8 like what is it doing there
hitting the d6 e5 diagonal like it's
completely counterintuitive i just
underestimated it was i was
thankfully during the game i did not
understand the seriousness of my mistake
probably because the vision still wasn't
that bad but i still felt some pressure
later on i think there was the next
critical moment was um
when you play netix b5
oh all the way down there yeah yeah
because
you can go through it quickly but but
before this um how how did you feel
about this position i thought if you
played 96 i was slightly worried right
so 96 king f6 right g3 and uh i'm sort
of g3 yes you consider rook f3 yeah rick
f3 and under g3 right or
what do you mean after king seven you
mean no no but why not king e5
ah not a faith ah okay okay yeah and
unfortunately this is kind of i see i
see so then then oh so we can get it
with the tempo okay yeah i was afraid of
some some stuff like this uh
um
yeah so this that is a nice trick so uh
yeah king e7 under g3 yes
then then uh then rg3 then maybe you
have rook f6 though so that's
okay it's not clear to break you but you
have rook c4 i guess then the rook is
coming yeah this is not looking great
maybe i can go 97 but it's just so ugly
right it's not clear where the
breakthrough is i don't think it's
objectively lost yet but it's certainly
considering where we started
uh this is he's definitely gotten
everything he could he could hope for
but um
yeah
perhaps i did not uh see this nf8 trick
immediately but um i definitely could
feel some danger because then atom b5 is
just sort of
just it's just there but it's
it's very much right if you even
consider that you have to go back right
well the point of not on b5 was
obviously to stunt the b the the um the
e file but once he was able to open up
the position
uh open up the uh you know the the
with the with the d4 break i i
misunderstood uh
sorry
miss evaluated uh the strength of this
movement and how uh poorly on my knight
would be misplaced yeah the angers
actually do say the objective if you
were lost uh after 96.96 well about a
plus four plus four yeah yeah that's so
you must have felt great relief to see
nike no of course yeah yeah i thought
it was just an easy draw
after this um
uh so yeah knight takes pawn takes and
you were not worried after this
no no i don't think that uh let's say
king to rick takes b5 um yeah if you
played rook f3 which maybe made your
life a little easier a little bit easier
but still after rook rook f3 king king
f6
um i mean sorry rook takes b5 king f6
king f2 king e3
and uh and king e5 at king three and
here um i was looking okay i could play
ricky seven but he suggested most
concrete is just to play rook to f4
and uh and then just take an h4 and
once the h pawn is sort of taken
i just don't think that you you can sort
of break right because
as any time you take this pawn the e the
e d d pawn sort of collapse and then the
a pawn is
not really enough to to to convert so
this was definitely uh
decent defense but yeah i could i really
could feel that the 96 was
was coming but thankfully i was not if i
if i realized how about it was i might
have hesitated leading to uh so
sometimes ignorance is truly bliss when
it comes to valuing positions you know
like for example erroneous
in our game he was just chilling you
know he was like he was like some of
these top guys are just chilling and i'm
like looking at them like they're crazy
but it's just sort of when you're when
you're relaxed i guess you can
defend better but sometimes if sometimes
you realize you're losing it makes
things worse you know right and well you
didn't collapse and actually got back
fully into the game made an important
draw here were the black pieces you're
feeling about the game in general
i think the preparation um
first of all it's decent it's decent the
black games against these top guys are
ridiculous you know because they're just
lenie is just such a
esteemed theoretician
so that was slightly intimidating
um
so the opening uh
perhaps i think that i'm slightly
disappointed that i should have been a
bit more familiar with this position
but i think in general he just played
quite well and uh
um
i think i
kept my calm uh because
because if i'm lost for 96 then i was it
was very bad long before that there
wasn't really much i could maybe there
was something i could do but
very very unpleasant for the most of the
game
hans we got to speak about the elephant
in the room you've asked
to have some words
so so um there's been a lot of things
that have been you know the social media
stuff and uh i just have a lot of things
to say and uh
you know i've thought a lot about what
what i want to say and how i'm going to
say it and i think i can just you know
maybe i'll forget something but let's
you know let's just discuss a few things
so first of all my accent you know like
i'm sorry this is just the first thing
this is like this is just the most funny
thing
because if you want me to speak like an
american right now i i can't even tell
but for the last two years
i have lived in a suitcase traveling
around europe playing chess non-stop
i spend so much time working on chess
that i simply don't go outside and
socialize with people who speak fluent
english
like this is just this is just one thing
i want to talk about i'm just
before i say anything like
i have spent the last two years
not spending any time in america
and even when i'm in america i don't go
outside other when i pick up my food i'm
just too busy with chess
so all these things saying that like i'm
faking an accent
and that like i'm putting on some facade
that is like the most ridiculous thing
i've ever said and and if anyone is
using my
my
newfound uh accent to make any
conclusions about anything chess related
is
like absolutely insane
because
like i've live i don't spend any time in
america i only speak the chess players
who have bad english so you maybe think
maybe it's
a product of my environment
okay maybe that was a bit true okay and
then
okay first of all the magnus opening
okay now uh let's get to get to that so
people were saying that uh there was no
idea why i checked this well
first of all you know people are
absolute idiots because the explanation
i'm going to give is going to make you
all look all the top gems look like
total idiots so
the position first of all they said
there was zero game there was a game
check the database there's this thing in
chess called transpositions okay now
when he played the move a3 of course i'm
expecting to move now to three now let's
say in the catalan no let's let's show
because this is just this is just
embarrassing um this is absolutely
embarrassing
and i'm sorry if i'm coming off hostile
it's just a passionate thing for me um
so let's go let's go to the so after
bishop so let's say the catalan let's
have the catalan
with the three with order yeah so let's
say you play not a three
okay
d5 g3 bishop b4 check wait there's a
move knight c3 here and then after
castles there's a move bishop g2 and
after dc4
a3 bishop c3 bc3 c5 we here we have we
in chess we call a transposition
now
let's say theoretically
magnus is playing been playing quite a
lot of catalan recently
so perhaps i'm looking at the catalan
and i'm thinking how is magnus going to
surprise me in the catalan
there's this weird move knight c3 i
remember some instances where he's go
for these very structures so this is a
perfectly reasonable thing and during
the moment i did not think about it
because it was such a small part of
preparation but simply
the pattern i recognized and and also i
spent 15 minutes
after the move a3 the reason i spent 15
minutes after the move a3 i don't know
if the time stamps are there
uh they are actually yeah so so how much
there was one moment where i spent yeah
eight minutes four eight eight minutes
okay anyways i was thinking more
from my hour 30. in general i spent 15
minutes now after the move a3 you know
take and now i play dc4
at this point since it's not a direct
transposition i should obviously take
some time to make sure that the position
is going to be transposed properly here
this move queen a4
i don't know this is a move that i was
concerned with again but now there's
bishop d7 i thought in the game queen
takes e4 bishop c6 knight f3 and then i
thought knight to d7 he plays castles i
thought bishop to d5 and then i play c5
and then i thought this was my plan so i
understood at least not in most
precise way but i understood that there
was going to be nine of three thus
leading to a transposition so this is
why i took some time people are saying
that that i'm taking time and then i'm
making up that a minute like i checked
it because it's a transposition i i'm
spending extra time to make sure that
the transmission is correct because it's
the world champion and he's just sprung
a very dangerous trap now if i don't
know this it can be very dangerous but
the fact that it's not a miracle it's
actually me being extremely tedious and
going through every single possible
transposition or or sort of line that he
that he could play in the catalan
that's the first thing okay
i i need to
there's just so many uh so many things
that uh uh so i think those are the main
things and then okay of course and then
the fact that my analysis is is not at
the level of a top player
for my game against frugia
you need to understand that when i play
the move queen to g3
i did not elaborate this during the game
this is a purely
psychological move
if if if clearly people don't know
anything about ferruja his style how to
beat him the way to beat him is to
attack him
he really really hates being attacked
and the main ways he lose loses is by
being attacked now we had a game in
miami where i got an attack
and i and he completely collapsed and i
studied previous games knowing attack so
when i see the position
when i say queen g3 i think to myself
okay i highly doubt based on my
intuitive feeling that i'm losing here
i don't feel the need
to calculate every single variation
because i'm confident that there's no
way first is gonna take and if he takes
he's gonna be shared shitless
okay
okay so that's that's this game now
after after the games first of all
you're extremely tired and and uh it's
extremely difficult
sometimes to recollect uh the
things that you're talking about the
moves the variations you know it's not
like i'm coming in here full of energy
right and especially in the analysis uh
okay you can debate full of energy but
like
it's not
sometimes you just you just fear things
so so the notion that that i simply
can't speak about chess on a high at a
high level is completely ridiculous um
i'm a very intuitive player i made a gut
call to play queen g3 and it paid off
and and and uh even if you look at the
pattern my games you know it's uh
i'm not i'm clearly missing many many
chances and it's extremely human chest
no no okay so this is
i think is that everything about
interviews have i covered everything
that's up to you no no i i have because
there's been the interviews have been a
key point um so that's just something i
wanted to cover that people are
ridiculous okay like my accent is i it's
i don't even i can't even realize
because i'm numb to it i'm not to it but
this is not this is not a facade i'm
sorry i just don't socialize much
because i work so hard at chess like i
i'm literally sorry i like have i delete
all social media i sit inside i study
chess and i leave to pick up my delivery
food twice a day that is my life i enjoy
it okay and if my english is not
as native uh as it is
uh sometimes
i'm sorry but when i speak to let's say
an american friend it comes right back
right it's something subconscious
so maybe now it's coming back anyways so
incriminating that's fine right so so
now i noticed throughout social media um
a lot of people uh who who i once had
respect for who who um who who i once
sort of looked up to a lot of my heroes
have decided to hop on this bandwagon
now
there have been a lot of speculation and
there's a lot of things set and i and
and and i think i'm the only one who
knows the truth so
so there's a few things that that need
to come to light
so first of all there's the the
situation with chess.com now people have
uh there have said that mychest.com was
was banned twice okay so this is what
happened when i was 12 years old
i was uh
with a friend and i was playing title
tuesday
and uh i was playing and he came over on
the ipad with an engine and i was 12
years old and he said you know
he started giving the moves i was a
child i had no idea what happened now
this happened once in an online
tournament
i was just a child and
nothing happened then now four years
later when i was 16 years old during my
streaming career
in an absolutely ridiculous mistake and
on rated games after that i had whenever
when i was 12 i have never ever in my
life cheated in an over the board game
in an online tournament if they were on
unrated games and i'm admitting this and
and i'm saying my truth because i do not
want any misrepresentation i am proud of
myself that i
learned from that mistake and now have
given everything to chess i have
sacrificed everything for chess and i do
everything i can to improve so i'm gonna
get started
basically
so
in some i wanted to gain some rating you
know i just wanted to get higher rates i
could play stronger players so i cheated
in random games on trust.com now i was
confronted i confessed and this is the
single biggest mistake of my life and
i'm completely ashamed and i'm telling
the world because
i do not want any misrepresentation and
i do not want rumors
i have never cheated in an over the
board game
other when i was 12 years old i have
never ever ever and i would never do
that that is the worst thing i could
ever do cheat in a tournament with prize
money now i made that mistake
and this is something i thought
something i was doing consistently never
when i was streaming did i cheat never
did i misrepresent my strength so i made
this mistake i was confronted by
trust.com i had fully admitted and i
stopped playing.com now
what i want people to know about this is
that
i'm deeply deeply sorry for my mistake
and i know that my actions have
consequences and i suffer those
consequences during that time i
completely step stepped away from a very
lucrative streaming career i stopped
playing at all events and i lost a lot
of close friendships and relationships
that meant a lot to me so i assure you
maybe i did not suffer but i'm putting
myself in the public now i could be
ruining my reputation for my life but i
want to tell the truth now this happened
i'm deeply deeply ashamed of it but keep
in mind i was 16 years old i never
wanted her anyone these are random games
i would never could even fathom doing it
in a real game
now
unfortunately now there has been a
targeted attack and
some recent events have made it really
really difficult for me to not stop
speaking
after the game against magnus obviously
magnus puts his tweet clearly
some insinuations and then everyone
starts to
pile i get
an email from chess.com saying that
they've privately removed access to my
chess.com account and that they have
uninvited me from the global chess
championship now
three days ago i met with someone very
high up in chess.com at the stingfield
cup had amazing amazing words but
because of this game against magnus
because of what he said they have
decided to completely remove me for the
website now this if this is big and now
this is after i have already fully
admitted and they have the best cheat
detection in the world they know that
i'm not a cheater and that i have given
i give everything interest i work so
hard at night i chess is my entire life
okay now if they're going to try to
think that i'm going to be silent about
what has happened it is completely
ridiculous i met with danny ranch
at miami and i would and and i january
was a person who confronted me and i was
deeply deeply
indebted to him for handling the the ban
privately and giving me the chance to
redeem myself
now after being after being not playing
chess.com events i went to over the
board tournaments and i decided to
myself that the only way to make up for
my mistake was to prove to myself and to
prove to others that i could win myself
now that has been my mission and that is
why i've lived in a suitcase for two
years that is why i have played 260
games in one year that is why i have
training 12 hours a day because i have
something to prove and now that
chestercom has suddenly decided to hop
on magnus's uh insinuations he carves
very direct accusations now they see the
opportunity okay we're just getting rid
of this i believe this is completely
unfair this is a targeted attack and if
you look at my games this is not
it has nothing to do with my games so
why do you specifically
why do you why does the ceo just come to
me and say we're looking forward to
having the global trust championship
we're looking forward
to you playing on our events and then
right when i beat magnus they decided to
remove my account and not let me play in
their tournaments this is absolutely
ridiculous and they've only done this
because of what magnus has said with
hikarus's and that the entire social
media chess world is completely
attacking me and undermining me but and
they maybe would think that i would be
afraid to tell the entire world that i
cheated into random games and i cheated
in a tournament when i was 12 years but
i'm not afraid because i know who i am
and i know the chess player that i'm and
i know what what i give to chess so i'm
not going to be scared to be manipulated
and to be conspired against to try to
ruin my chest career when i know what
has happened so
you know
this
as far as magnus this is absolutely the
fact that he did it without saying it he
knew the insinuations that would follow
if you look at social media every single
platform i'm getting thousands of
messages not thousands uh there are
thousands of tweets everyone is
attacking me
and and uh some people are defending me
and i really appreciate those but when i
see people attack me with absolutely
zero evidence i you know
people have zero i'm the only person who
knows what happened and i'm telling you
guys that this is this is the truth now
i i you know i really do not think that
i would have the courage to to say this
but some people i'm very thankful to the
people who who help help me make this
vision and you know what um
this is this is the truth and uh i
really
and now magnus can uh and hikaru uh uh
hikaru i've never ever cheated against
you in an online game any
never happened
and uh
and and and the most ridiculous part uh
and this uh is is that um you know the
same players that in this tournament are
in singing that i'm cheating
have also made insinuations about people
who are making considerations about me
so let's just say the people who are
saying these things about me
they're not that innocent themselves so
it's it's very ridiculous um so so you
know i'm sorry if i'm i'm i'm rambling
but the main thing that i want to say is
that i am not going to let chess.com i'm
not going to let magnus carlsen i'm not
going to let hikara nakamura the three
arguably biggest entities in chess
simply slander my reputation
because
the question is why are you going to
remove me from trust.com right after i
beat magnus just uh what's what's what's
with the timing so um i i would first of
all you know again i'm deeply deeply
sorry for what has happened is the
biggest single regret of my life i could
and even now to look back on it i cannot
recognize myself to give context i was
16 years old i don't want to make
excuses but i was living alone in new
york city it was peak at the pandemic
and at that i've been financially
independent since i was 16 years old i
left my family and i was living alone at
16 i had rent to pay and i wanted to you
know and i was willing to do anything to
grow my stream so of course i made a
childish mistake and i will have to live
with that
but i'd rather live with that with
everyone knowing the truth instead of
people making simple uh uh you know
speculation about about me because this
is the full truth and i'd like to see if
everyone else can can can actually tell
their truth when charizard com sends you
this email did they give a reasoning no
reason they're just informed they just
no reason they said i i tried to log
into my trust.com account
i wanted to check the games and uh they
said we have i could log in send me an
email
a few hours later they've rescinded her
we have privately so they didn't want to
ban me publicly because i didn't have to
give a reason
and they think that they can scare me
and because they think that i'm not
going that i'm not going to talk about
it because i'm afraid to admit this but
this is an online i did this when i was
12 years old and then when i and then
the sec other times i did it it was not
even
over the worship it was not even in a
prize money online it was an absolute
random game and i understand that some
people might lose respect for me for
this but it is my greatest mistake and
i've done everything i've done in the
past few years
has been to to make up for that mistake
and that is my entire
purpose as a chess player is to prove to
myself and for others that
i'm trying to to do better and i hope
that my results uh and my commitment and
my hard work has shown that i've i've
learned from this and that um
i i learned my lesson hans
how does it feel to play the rest of the
tournament knowing that everything here
is surrounding
the sinkhole cup magnus left and clearly
uh something is happening how are you
able to focus uh because you know when
obviously before after the game i open
social media and i can't get my eyes off
it because uh
every single person in their in their
whole family has an opinion and of
course you sort of get dragged into it
and i'm reading it and i'm uh it's
obviously it was really disheartening
seeing so many people and you know what
i i would like to say this is when you
know when i was eight years old
um i went magnus carlson came to an
exhibition in california and my mom took
me there i just started or maybe has
nine i just started playing chess and he
was doing a blindfold silent there was
an auction to bid on it
and uh when when they were bidding on it
uh it got up to a thousand dollars and
it became too much and my mom was like
no if you really really want it we'll do
it you know she was going to really to
make a financial sacrifice so
i could play and i said no no mom one
day i'm going to play him for free
okay and instead i got a signed
big chess piece and you know that
happened but to me to see my hero
to see my absolute hero
try to to to
target um try to ruin my reputation for
my chess career and to do it in such a a
frivolous way is really really
disappointing
um because you know you spend your
entire life looking up to someone and
then you meet them and then
you know my dream came true i lived my
dream for a day beating magnus and then
all this happened so
i'm sorry i forgot what your initial
question was
how do you focus on the sing phil cup
well you know when i sit on the board
it's it's pure it's all chess so even
even today maybe there were moments
during the game where my mind wandered
but when i'm playing chess that's all
that's that's all there was on my mind
and hopefully it'll stay that way does
this
bothering you
fuel you does it make you hungry it
absolutely fuels me you know my my fuel
um has always been um maybe not anger
but spite has been has been a strong
fuel for me when i was starting to play
chess in the netherlands my school
teacher told me i wasn't good enough
and that certainly fueled me i've always
been been one to prove people wrong and
this this absolutely fuels me and this
makes me want to win the tournament even
more and you know i can i can come to
the game i can completely strip you want
to do any fair play check to me you want
i don't care because i i know that i'm
clean and
they could literally tell me those
ridiculous things they want me to ship
fully naked
i'll do it i don't care because i know i
know that i'm clean and uh i'm willing
to subject myself you want you want me
to play in a in a in a
closed box with zero electric
transmission i don't care you know
name whatever you guys want um
i'm here to win and uh that's gonna be
my goal regardless
hans very candid words guys any
questions on the contrary a very
heartfelt interview
uh
your motion
spoke for itself
hans all we can say is enjoy your free
day stay away from social media and uh
keep your head in the game yeah i think
much of this needed to be said and i
think it's very good that it has been
said uh and yeah thanks uh thanks for
coming in and doing this yeah and uh i
just uh before i go i just thank you
guys uh for for giving me the chance to
speak and
i'm sure many many people are are going
to be seeing this and uh i just would
like to to hope that everyone keeps an
open mind and uh and understands that uh
chess is my entire life and uh i've
sacrificed everything for this game and
i'm willing to do anything
um to to to prove and to improve myself
and to improve at chess so so this is
i'm sorry but the chess is everything to
me so uh
i think that's all that's all i need to
say absolutely you've said plenty hands
thanks for joining us here guys we're
coming up on a rest day has still on
plus one trying to win this tournament
yes he is
and again uh peter very heartfelt words
yeah it feels like we really should not
be talking right now this this needs to
be how this broadcast ends because
like we we are not adding any value to
what han said here